[Musique]
avec nous Marie Berthe des groseilliers
les présidentes et chefs de la direction
du groupe BMTC bonsoir madame des
groseilliers bonsoir alors c'est quand
même tout un gros changement pour
l'entreprise la disparition de
l'enseigne bruit Martino qui était quand
même bien connu des Québécois pourquoi
vous avez décidé de mettre le nom
tanguin partout bon en fait une décision
que comme vous dites
c'est une question qui a pris un certain
temps une évaluation très exhaustive par
le groupe BTC en fait on a évalué on a
aussi on a aussi des déterminer laquelle
des bannières qui pourraient
s'expansionner puis le mieux s'exploiter
puis se déployer à travers la province
et puis Tanguay vraiment pour nous
c'était la bannière à exploiter à
travers le Québec c'était l'objectif
c'était d'unifier nos bailleurs une
force de frappe puis on a sélectionné la
bannière Tanguay et là ce qu'on comprend
c'est qu'il y a entre autres 11 magasins
qui vont dorénavant être transformés en
Tanguay mais lorsqu'on lit entre les
LIGNES c'est la Morse d'une expansion il
y en aura d'autres par la suite des
magasins Tanguay sûrement dans un dans
un futur mais pour le moment on se
concentre Tanguy qui était dans l'aise
du Québec maintenant commence à
découvrir un nouveau marché qui est
l'ouest du Québec clairement il y a un
marché qui était là pour les bananes
remplacent physiquement les magasins
donc c'est un marché qu'on a déjà une
clientèle qu'on connaît déjà mais quand
même la direction de Tanguay va devoir
apprendre à marcher comprendre le marché
de Montréal être là pour nos clients les
supporter et puis quand on aura fait ça
on regardera les possibilités qui
s'offrent à nous très bien alors là à
partir de maintenant le nom des magasins
change les enseignes seront changés dans
les prochains jours tout au plus mais
pas seulement les noms madame des
groseilliers jusqu'à 80% des produits
sur les planchers vont être différents
en fait qu'est-ce qui va changer pour le
consommateur en fait c'est ça fait
partie un des choix pour qu'on a choisi
la bannière tanguée plutôt que la
bannière brille Martineau depuis trois
ans la bannière Tanguay a pris une
la direction où ils ont sélectionné pour
offrir aux clients un tout pour la
maison donc on retrouve pas juste les
produits typiques qu'on retrouvait chez
bromers Tanguy à l'époque qui était
meubles électroménager électronique
matelas mais c'est vraiment un tout pour
la maison je m'excuse pour le
languitisme mais vraiment un One Stop
ce que puisse donc c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait et c'est ce qu'on va apporter à la
région métropolitaine de Montréal et ses
environs Drummondville Sherbrooke c'est
vraiment de ramener cette expérience
tanguella où on retrouve toute une gamme
de produits plus de 30 000 produits en
magasin comme sur l'Internet quelque
chose qu'il y avait pas chez brow et
Martineau mais là qui on va retrouver
chez Tanguy puis en fait c'est aussi
l'expérience que le client va pouvoir
venir en magasin avec le budget qu'il a
que ce soit un budget plus modif ou un
budget élaboré il va pouvoir trouver ce
qu'il veut selon son budget selon ses
besoins parce que ça c'est une
inquiétude évidemment on est en période
d'inflation tout coûte plus cher on se
demande s'il y aura pas récession à
l'horizon les gens sont extrêmement
sensibles au prix madame des
Groseilliers et il y a de grandes
enseignes aux États-Unis par exemple qui
font des prévisions 10 ans les prochains
mois seront pas faciles est-ce que
est-ce que ça va vouloir dire des
hausses de prix pour les consommateurs
qui étaient habitués chez Bruay Martino
et là qui entreront plutôt dans des
tangues non justement c'est ça
l'objectif une des questions qu'on a
pris pour la bannière en ayant une force
de frappe une bannière à travers le
Québec comprendrez qu'on réduit nos
coûts on a créé des synergies
incroyables importantes qui fait que on
peut se permettre d'avoir une plus
grosse plus grosse pouvoir de
négociation que nous fournisseurs
l'objectif c'est toujours d'offrir le la
plus grande panoplie de produits au
meilleur prix pour nos consommateurs
donc ça fait partie de cette décision là
cette décision-là va permettre aussi
attendu d'établir son leadership dans le
marché du commerce des détails dans le
domaine où on est on exerce on sort
d'une période pandémique ou ça a été
favorable évidemment au détaillant que
ce soit d'électroménager d'ameublement
tout le monde rénové investissait à
l'intérieur les ont beaucoup grimpé
pendant cette période-là il y a eu
toutes sortes de problèmes dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement aussi
qu'est-ce qui en est de l'expérience
pour le consommateur en ce moment est-ce
que c'est toujours aussi long d'avoir
les produits et est-ce que les prix se
sont aussi également très appréciés oui
en fait un peu comme le domaine de
construction les prix oui ont explosé à
cause de tous les problèmes il y a la
covid pour les production de de de
d'exportation c'est tout ça les prix se
sont rétablis quand même assez dans le
marché autant au niveau du coma de
détails on fait notre possible pour
offrir tout ce qu'on peut au client
c'est ce qu'on fait on offre des prix
abordables à des prix des des produits
abordables comme des produits de haut de
gamme donc non on est vraiment on est
vraiment sur le dans le marché et puis
on fait attention à nos clients puis on
s'assure que on est là pour eux puis
qu'on peut répondre à leurs besoins
est-ce que ce n'est qu'un début cette
transformation madame des groseilliers
est-ce qu'il y a une suite est-ce qu'il
y a d'autres défis qui vous attendent
par la suite chez Tanguay mais là pour
le moment ça a été un gros défi ça
menant qu'on travaille sur ce projet-là
ça a commencé avec l'immigration
informatique après ça la restructuration
opérationnelle et ensuite commerciale de
fusionner nos services administratifs
donc ça a été un travail très
d'arrache-pied pour la beaucoup de nos
employés donc là on va prendre un petit
peu de respirer travailler s'assurer que
Tanguy s'est établit bien dans la région
métropolitaine de Montréal qui
comprennent bien le marché comprennent
bien nos consommateurs à Montréal et
puis après ça on verra où on s'en va
très bien on va vous suivre de près
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]